INTEL COMMITTEE CHAIR, AGAIN
NUNES HAS SENT A LETTER
TONIGHT TO SESSIONS THAT
SAYS THE FISA SURVEILLANCE
APPLICATION FOR CARTER PAGE,
A CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE IN THE
TRUMP ASSOCIATION FOR THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN APPEARS TO BE
A CLEAR VIOLATION OF FBI
RULES FOR SUBMITTING
EVIDENCE TO THE FISA COURT
578 MAY VIOLATE CRIMINAL
STATUTES.
MARK LEVIN'S LEGAL
FOUNDATION HAS ALSO FILED A
MOTION.
THEY ARE ASKING THE FISA
COURT TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THE SUSPECTED ABUSES
ALLEGEDLY COMMITTED BY THE
FBI AND THE DOJ ALSO THE
HOITS THE NEW COLLEAGUE WE
ARE PROUD TO HAVE HIM LIFE,
LIBERTY LEVINE, GREAT ONE.
ALSO THE HOST OF LEVINE TV,
CRTV MARK LEVIN.
THIS NUNES MEMO THAT I HAVE
HERE THAT THE FBI THAT THE
FBI COULD HAVE COMMITTED
CRIMES AND THAT THEY BROKE
PROTOCOL.
DON'T WE ALREADY KNOW WHEN
YOU DON'T TELL A FISA JUDGE
IN YOUR INITIAL APPLICATION,
SUBSEQUENT RENEWAL
APPLICATIONS THAT HILLARY
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR THE
DOSSIER AND IT WAS NEVER
VERIFIED AND THE LAW
SPECIFICALLY SAYS TO VERIFY
IT, DON'T WE KNOW THAT THEY
VIOLATED THE LAW, MARK
LEVIN, CONSTITUTIONAL
SCHOLAR?
>> YOU KNOW, ASHANTE.
LET ME TELL YOU
SET ME TELL YOU
SEANME TELL YOU
SEAN H TELL YOU
SEAN HANELL YOU
SEAN HANNIL YOU
SEAN HANNITYYOU
SEAN HANNITY.OU
SEAN HANNITY.THE JUDGES ON FISAC
SEAN HANNITY.THE JUDGES ON FISAU
SEAN HANNITY.THE JUDGES ON FISAT
HAVE GOTTEN AWAY WITHOUT
BEING SCRUTINIZED.
IF YOU ARE A FEDERAL JUDGE.
FORGET ABOUT THE FISA COURT.
FEDERAL DISTRICT COURT.
PA PELL LAT COURT, THE
SUPREME COURT AND YOU KNOW
AS A MATTER OF FACT THAT YOU
WERE MISLEAD, AND I WANT
EVERYONE TO LISTEN TO THIS.
AND YOU KNOW AS A MATTER OF
FACT THAT THE INFORMATION
THATS WOULD PROVIDED TO YOU
OR THE INFORMATION THAT
WASN'T PROVIDED FOR FULL
CONTEXT LED TO YOU ISSUE A
WARRANT TO SPY ON AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN UNDER THE
IDEA THAT THE AMERICAN
CITIZEN WAS AN AGENT OF
RUSSIA LIKELY TO COMMIT A
CRIME AND BY THE WAY THAT
CITIZEN, CARTER PAGE, LAST
TIME I CHECKED HE HASN'T
BEEN CHARGED WITH ANYTHING.
IF YOU ARE A JUDGE AND WE
HAVE HAD SUCCESSIVE JUDGES
IN THIS FISA COURT OVER A
PERIOD OF ONE YEAR AND YOU
DON'T DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT,
CONGRESSMAN NEEDS TO LOOK
INTO THIS.
I DO NOT EXPECT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
INVESTIGATE THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
I JUST DON'T.
I DON'T EXPECT THE FBI TO
INVESTIGATE THE FBI.
BUT I DAMN WELL EXPECT
FEDERAL JUDGES SERVING AS
FISA COURT JUDGES TO MAKE
SURE THAT CONDUCT WASN'T
COMMITTED IN FRONT OF THEM.
NOW, LET ME TELL YOU
SOMETHING.
LAST APRIL, LAND MARK LEGAL
FOUNDATION FILED SECRETLY
WITH THE FISA COURT BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE ANY STANDING.
NOBODY HAS STANDING.
NOBODY REALLY KNOWS HOW THIS
WORKS.
WE SAID TO THE COURT, HEY
COURT, HEY JUDGE, GUESS
WHAT?
GUESS WHAT JUST TOOK PLACE
IN YOUR COURTROOM?
HERE IS WHAT HE WEED YOU
HAVE THE INHERENT
JURISDICTION TO ORDER AN
INVESTIGATION OF THE FBI TO
GET ANSWERS TO THIS.
NUMBER ONE.
LAST APRIL.
HAVE THIS COURT'S ORDER OR
ORDERS BEEN USED BY
INTELLIGENT ENTITIES OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS A
SUBTERFUGE TO SURVEIL
PRIVATE CITIZENS AND AT
LEAST ONE UNITED STATES
SENATOR WE WERE THINKING OF
SESSIONS AT THE TIME FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES.
NUMBER TWO, DID GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS SEEK ONE OR MORE
NATIONAL SECURITY
SURVEILLANCE WARRANTS FROM
THIS COURT AS A PRETEXT TO
CONDUCT AN INVESTIGATION FOR
THE PURPOSE OF AFFECTING AN
ONGOING NATIONAL
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN AND
SUBSEQUENT TRANSITION OF AN
INCOMING PRESIDENT?
THIS IS LAST APRIL.
NUMBER THREE, WHEN APPLYING
TO THIS COURT FOR ONE OR
MORE WARRANTS IN THIS
MATTER.
DID THE FBI INFORM THIS
COURT.
PAID SOME OF THE EXPENSES OF
A FORMER BRITISH SPY WHO
PREPARED THE DOSSIER,
REPORTEDLY RELIED ON IN
WHOLE OR PART, IN ITS
APPLICATION TO CONVINCE THIS
COURT TO ISSUE A WARRANT.
NUMBER FOUR, WHEN APPLYING
TO THIS COURT, THIS IS US TO
THE JUDGE, FOR ONE OR MORE
WARRANTS IN THIS MATTER, DID
THE FBI INFORM THIS COURT
THAT THE DOSSIER IT
REPORTEDLY PRESENTED IN
PURSUIT OF ONE OR MORE
WARRANTS HAD ORIGINALLY BEEN
PREPARED BY THE FORMER
BRITISH SPY FOR A WASHINGTON
RESEARCH FIRM CONDUCTING
OPPOSITION RESEARCH AGAINST
THE REPUBLICAN NOMINEE FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES DONALD J. TRUMP?
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
LANDMARK LEGAL FOUNDATION
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS THE
COURT, THE JUDGE, THE FISA
JUDGE, SITTING EN BANC, BY
HERSELF.
THAT SHE SHOULD DIRECT THE
GOVERNMENT TO COMPLETE ITS
INVESTIGATION AND REPORT ITS
FINDINGS TO THE COURT WITHIN
90 DAYS.
THE COURT SHOULD ALSO
CONSIDER WHETHER IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO ISSUE AN
ORDER TO ALL RELEVANT
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES TO
SHOW CAUSE AS TO WHY THEY
SHOULD NOT BE HELD IN
CONTEMPT FOR FAILING TO
PROTECT THE SECRECY OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
OBTAINED PURSUANT TO THE
COURT ORDER.
NOW, DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
JUDGE SAID IN RESPONSE TO
US, THE FISA COURT JUDGE?
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO
THIS.
APRIL 25, 2017.
THIS IS ROSEMARY COLLIER,
THE PRESIDING JUDGE, KEEP IN
MIND, THE JUDGES ON THE FISA
COURT ARE PICKED BY THE
CHIEF JUSTICE OF THE SUPREME
COURT.
SHE WROTE IN THIS LITTLE
ORDER, THE HAS RECEIVED A
PLEADING TITLED MOTION FOR
LEAVE TO APPEAR AS A ME CAN
YOU SAY CURIAE ON AND ON.
>> EXPLAIN THAT.
>> FIVE DAYS LATER SHE SAYS
ALTHOUGH PRESENTED AS A
REQUEST TO APPEAR, THERE IS
NO MATTER PENDING BEFORE THE
COURT WITH RESPECT TO WHICH
SUCH AN APPEARANCE WOULD BE
PROPER THIS WARRANT EXTENDED
THREE TIMES.
THIS MATTER WAS STILL
APPEARING BEFORE THIS COURT.
THAT'S NUMBER ONE, NUMBER
TWO, THE COURT HAS ONGOING
JURISDICTION TO SUPERVISE
THE CONDUCT OF ATTORNEYS,
THE FBI, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, BEFORE THE
COURT.
CONTEMPT MAY REACH
BACKWARDS.
EVEN AFTER A CASE HAS BEEN
CONCLUDED.
IN OTHER WORDS, THIS FISA
JUDGE AND QUITE FRANKLY, WAS
MISDIRECTING WHEN SHE SAID
THE MATTER IS NOT BEFORE US
ANYMORE WHEN IT WAS STILL
BEFORE THEM AND THIS COURT,
LIKE ANY FEDERAL COURT,
STILL HAS THE POWER TO REACH
BACK AND HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
SHE DID NOTHING.
SHE DID NOT CALL IN THE FBI
AS FAR AS WE KNOW.
SHE DID NOT CALL IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
SHE DID NOT ASK FOR AN
INVESTIGATION.
SHE DIDN'T HOLD A CONTEMPT
HEARING.
NOTHING.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT TELLS
ME?
SOMETHING SMELLS LIKE A RAT.
WHICH MEANS THIS:
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU
THIS.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> THIS IS ALL GREAT
INFORMATION.
MARK, THIS IS HOW I SEE
THIS.
REMEMBER THE GRASSLEY GRAHAM
MEMO, HUGE NEWS.
THEY SAID THE BULK OF THE
FISA APPLICATION CONSISTED
OF WHAT WE NOW KNOW TO BE
UNVERIFIED INFORMATION.
FUSION G.P.S.
THE FBI NEVER VERIFIED.
THE DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR
ANDREW MCCABE LITERALLY SAID
NO DOSSIER, NOT EVEN AN
APPLICATION.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT'S RENEWED EVERY 90 DAYS.
SO, IF YOU HAVE AN
OPPOSITION PARTY CANDIDATE
USING UNVERIFIED RUSSIAN
LIES IN THE LEAD-UP AND POST
ELECTION, TO UNDERMINE A
PRESIDENT, AND -- WHAT WE
KNOW AS OF NOW IS NONE OF IT
IS TRUE.
IS THIS BASED ON YOUR
KNOWLEDGE OF HISTORY AT
LEAST A BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER AND CORRUPTION IN YOUR
LIFETIME?
BECAUSE TO ME ARE YOU
KIDDING WHEN YOU AND I SPOKE
WAY BACK MARCH OF LAST YEAR,
AND WE LAYED THIS OUT.
WE RECALLED KOOKS,
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS.
WE DIDN'T HAVE A LOT.
I WAS FOCUSED ON THE FISA
ABOUT THE FISA COURT.
I WANT TO UNDERSCORE
SOMETHING TONIGHT, SEAN, IT
IS THIS.
THESE FEDERAL JUDGES SITTING
ON THIS FISA COURT ACT LIKE
THEY HAVE NO ROLE IN THIS.
>> Sean: BOLOGNA.
>> THEY WERE ABUSED.
THE COURT WAS ABUSED.
PEOPLE WERE MISLEAD.
PEOPLE SHOULD BE HELD A
COUNT.
THEY READ THE NEWSPAPERS
NOW.
THEY WATCH TELEVISION NOW.
WE PRESENTED THIS JUDGE WITH
THE EVIDENCE AND FILED IT.
>> Sean: LAST THING.
>> CONGRESS NEEDS TO FIND
OUT NOW WHY THESE JUDGES
EVEN TODAY AREN'T HOLDING
THESE PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Sean: REMEMBER, COMEY
SAID TO TRUMP IN JANUARY OF
2017 IN TRUMP TOWER, OH,
IT'S SALACIOUS AND IT'S
UNVERIFIED.
THE FISA APPLICATION, THE
FIRST ONE WAS THREE MONTHS
EARLIER HE BY HIS OWN WORDS
IS ADMITTING HE VIOLATED AS
GREGG JARRETT EARLIER AS
MANY AS SIX LAWS.
THESE ARE FELONIES, MARK.
YOU DON'T LIE BEFORE A JUDGE
NOR DO YOU PRESENT
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
THE CONSTITUTION.
>> I'M TALKING ABOUT A COURT
NEEDS TO PROTECT ITSELF.
>> Sean: AGREED.
>> ANY FEDERAL COURT IN
AMERICA IN SOMEBODY LIES TO
CUTER.
OMITS.
A COURT IS MISLEAD, FEDERAL
JUDGES EVERY DAY THEY HOLD
PEOPLE TO ACCOUNT.
THESE JUDGES IN THE FISA
COURT.
LET ME SAY THIS QUICKLY.
>> LAST WORD.
>> IT'S TIME TO ABOLISH THE
FISA COURT.
DEVELOP A NEW INTELLIGENCE
RELATED COURT.
SHOULD NOT EXISTING FEDERAL
JUDGES.
THEY SHOULD BE CONFIRMED.
NOT FOR LIFE TERMS.
FOR GIVEN TERMS.
THE FBI AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, WHERE THEY GO
INTO THAT COURT SHOULD NOT
BE ALONE ANYMORE.
THERE OUGHT TO BE AN OFFICE
WITHIN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT'S THERE TO
ENSURE THAT CIVIL LIBERTIES
ARE PROTECTED THERE ARE
THINGS WE NEED TO DO WITH
THIS COURT RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: LIFE, LIBERTY,
LEVINE SUNDAY NIGHTS, 10:00
EASTERN.
WHO ARE IS YOUR GUEST THIS
WEEKEND?
>> WE HAVE A FULL HOUR WITH
CHAIRMAN NUNES.
>> Sean: AWESOME.
>> WE GO OVER EVERYTHING
SOUP TO NUTS.
>> Sean: I LOVE.
THIS I HOPE EVERYBODY